dégustation et ateliers de fabrication
de bougies la journée happy days
organisés à la verrière dans la maison
de quartier du bois de l'étang
ce jeudi 16 juin a mis à l'honneur la
bei l'occasion pour les élèves de ce1 et
ce2 de l'école du bois de l'étang de
découvrir cet insecte une journée
s'inscrivant dans le cadre scolaire avec
des objectifs pédagogiques davantage
c'est de venir voir en pratique ce qu'on
a étudié ou ce qu'on va étudier en
classe et de rendre ça plus concret pour
les enfants c'est dans la découverte du
monde le monde du vivant c'est ce qu'on
étudie à l'école la chaîne alimentaire
le développement durable c'est les
enfants ont pu participer à l'extraction
du miel réalisé par l'apiculteur
référent de la verrière gérer la journée
parce que je me dis le miel et
et découvrir les abbés moi j'aimais bien
qu'on avait fait les bouger quand on
avait goûté au moins des abeilles
pourquoi les traits des abeilles et
montre à paris et alors avec les happy
days et ses ateliers ludiques
les apiculteurs veulent alerter les
jeunes sur les dangers de l'extinction
des abeilles aujourd'hui 80% de nos
ressources alimentaires dépendent de
l'activité de cet insecte notamment à
travers son rôle joué dans la
reproduction des plantes
ça leur permet d'être sensibilisés au
respect de la bei et de la plante et de
tout l'environnement et surtout au
niveau des enfants c'est très important
parce que c'est l'avenir de notre
société
donc il faut les sensibiliser dès leur
très jeune âge à respecter les abeilles
et tout leur environnement
la disparition des abeilles conduit plus
de 1000 apiculteur à cesser leur
activité chaque année une mortalité
importante causée par l'utilisation des
pesticides et l'apparition de prédateurs
comme le frelon asiatique